the Palestinians don't want them I mean
oddly enough the Palestinians would
prefer Hamas at this point they have
like a 75% approval rating why because
they committed these atrocities against
you so the one thing that America
refuses to recognize is just how
radicalized the Palestinian people have
become this notion that it's just Hamas
40,000 terrorists and then 2 million
peaceloving people that once Hamas once
the Yoke of Hamas is taken off you have
this great opportunity for peace it's
not true
all right Ambassador David fredman I
have to say it's a pleasure to have you
in my home but this will not feel as uh
say warm as warm and fuzzy as last time
we did this in Jerusalem just about six
or seven months ago um in light of
everything that's going on in Israel so
I guess first what are you doing in
Florida right now why don't we start
there and then we'll talk about
everything else well I uh I I I just
came for a few weeks to see my family
down here uh I had been in uh Israel
when the war started uh with uh some
other family members with some
grandchildren um I had to explain to uh
to my 12-year-old granddaughter my
oldest grandchild uh as we you know
rushed her into the safe room um you
know that that that there was a whole
world out there whole ugly world out
there that you know we hope our children
never get to know you know and she would
ask me uh you know why uh why are there
people that want to kill us uh so
indiscriminately I mean she didn't use
that word but why are they shooting
Rockets us they never met us they don't
know us why do they hate us so much that
they want to kill us and that was a hard
conversation to have you know so that's
that's where I was and you know after a
few weeks of that then I thought I uh I
thought I could be helpful here doing
some some some media some advocacy so I
came to uh the states for a few weeks so
just to be clear because a few things
are changing on the ground as we're
speaking right now it's sounds like
there might be a prisoner swap and some
of the hostages might be released we
we're airing this on Wednesday or we're
we're taping this Wednesday before
Thanksgiving we're airing this Sunday
after what would you say the state of
the country is at the moment I mean
there's still a fullscale war going in
every inch North to Southeast to West
look uh the the the country was in shock
for a couple of days but then that you
know that turned to anger and that very
quickly turned to determination and they
are determined to win this war and to
eradicate Hamas and and that's the real
objective now you overlay on that um the
the human tragedy of 240 hostages you
know whose families are enduring the
type of trauma and torture that none of
us should ever know and of course the
ones who are held in captivity are
probably enduring the same so uh Israel
has these two goals that are not
entirely consistent with each other
right win the war eradicate clas but do
it in a way where you can extract as
many hostages as possible so yeah we
don't know what the deal is yet by the
time this airs we probably will know
what it is whether that deal is kept
whether it's you know what what what
happens after that you know it's it's a
dynamic fluid situation Israel has done
this before having to trade prisoners
for hostages sometimes literally to just
get remains back of Israelis well never
like this though never like this but
nothing like this of course but how did
they even go in and
negotiate with people that did this in
the first place it's not like you know I
think a lot of people are struggling a
lot of westerners that don't really
understand what's going on in Israel
struggle to understand the disproportion
they always talk about disproportionate
but the disproportion realities between
the two parties here yeah look back in
2006 after the um Lebanon war they
negotiated for for two um Two Soldiers
and they didn't know whether the
soldiers were alive or dead and we all
waited for the exchange and uh
everybody's heart sank as we saw two
bodies two body bags being brought over
the Border um that's how that's how you
know kind of Despicable and
untrustworthy these negotiations are so
um yeah there'll be I'm sure some
unpleasant surprises here but remember
you know uh one soldier gilad Shalit was
traded for almost 5,000 Hamas terrorists
many of whom then returned to commit
acts of of Terror and murder so that was
one now you're talking about um 240
women children elderly people Holocaust
Survivors um
and they're trickling them out you know
they're gonna do maybe I'm hearing 10 a
day for five days um it's it's it's just
the whole thing is barbaric and I you
know but one thing about Israel that I
don't think people understand it's a
country of Jewish Mothers you know the
the the desire to see people uh saved
the the the discomfort that every
Israeli has going to sleep at night
knowing that somebody's kids are
unaccounted for and they're being held
in tunnels it's unbearable so uh as
tough as they are and they're incredibly
tough and strong and great Fighters
they're also a lot of Jewish Mothers
just want their kids back and this this
balance um you know it's it's it's
really a tough decision to make for the
leaders of the country to make that
decision is that the weird thing that's
going on here that it's kind of baked
into the code that the Jews will survive
this that these horrible things happen
that's what every holiday and most of
the holidays are about and a bunch of us
are killed mhm then here we are and
let's acknowledge what happened and
let's eat and continue and and that sort
of feels like what's going to happen
here too look um I no doubt Israel is
going to survive um you know one of the
important perspectives here is think
about um you know 1200 um people were
slaughtered on on the uh 7th of
October so to compare that for example
to the Holocaust right that event in
Holocaust terms happened every day for
four years picture October 7th every
single day for 4 years and that's the
Holocaust and we survive the Holocaust
right so we're going to survive this um
but we're not we're not you know we're
not our parents or our grandparents you
know I mean I'm not as tough as my
grandparents were I mean I didn't grow
up that way I grew up in a very
comfortable life as you probably did and
everybody else we know right well we
both grew up in Long Island about three
three miles away from each other it was
okay we're not cut out we're not cut out
for this we're not cut out to be you
know ripped away from our parents and
stuck in a and a and a hole in the
ground I mean that's not what our G
thank God it's not who we
are um so now you know this this this
episode is uh is causing all of us to
think about what we're made of and how
strong we are and how we're going to
survive we will survive but um it's
causing everybody to really rethink all
their assumptions how do you feel I mean
as the former US ambassador to Israel in
a time of Peace a time of really
extraordinary peace and peace deals and
there were seemingly the other peace
deals that were about to be signed it
sounds like Saudi Arabia might have been
signed the following week I mean the the
contrast of what you saw there and what
you helped make happen there versus
where we're at now it's just got to be
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing it's it's
frustrating I I'll tell you you know my
wife said to me the other day aren't you
glad you're not there now and I said no
actually I'm really frustrated that I'm
not there now I would love to be there
now because um uh well I I I can't tell
you I i' achieve a better outcome it's
it's an unprovable at least in my mind
uh I know how I would deal with these
with these barbarians and it'll be very
different because I that with them
before we had these we had these
skirmishes before it wasn't anything
like this but when I was in office 2019
Hamas you have shot rockets and
attempted at least to kidnap some
soldiers um we delivered very different
messages at all times to the highest you
know levels through intermedi
intermediaries sometimes directly you
know you harm one hair on an American
you know will will wipe you out you you
harm one hair on an Israeli the Israelis
will wipe you out with our enthusiastic
support you know we we didn't leave any
room for ambiguity we didn't talk about
you know a two-state solution we didn't
talk about you know Palestinian dignity
we just didn't touch that stuff we just
said we're not interested we'll talk
about that when things are quiet right
now um You you end this or we will you
know uh unleash the full Wrath of both
the American or Israel government
whatever is applicable and um I mean I'd
love to be delivering that message right
now unfortunately it's it's it's
meaningless from somebody who's no
longer in office well so what do you
think happened in terms of messaging
that clearly Hamas or the guys running
it in Qatar or the Iranians got a
different message either tacitly or or
suddenly that they would be able to get
away with something like this um I mean
look it began it began with Afghanistan
it it continued through through uh
Russia and Ukraine it's it's a function
of a president who just you know spews
weakness I mean you know just doesn't
have the the the Acuity or the uh or the
Vigor to really portray America as a
strong country um we gave $6 billion to
Iran we're about to give another $10
billion to Iran we lifted all the
sanctions on Iran that we had in place
you know Iran when we left office was
selling about a billion dollars worth of
oil you know uh in a couple of years now
they're up to 60 or 70 billion dollar a
year we made Iran a very rich country
they were broke when we left they were
broke and on top of that we had you know
assassinated their their head the head
of the snake if you will the head
sponsor the head architect of all the
terror attacks and he around didn't
response nothing because they were
afraid of us so losing that deterrence
is really the I think the single event
that has caused all these problems to
happen that uh you know we spend 7800
you know billion dollars a year on our
military if no one thinks we're going to
use it if no one thinks that we didn't
know how to use it it's a waste of money
is that just the reality of the Middle
East that that it really just boils down
to that more than anything else you know
you can just say nice things it's just
not how it works over there yeah look in
in in in the Arab dialect you know when
people say it doesn't matter uh they
have a phrase in Arabic it translates to
it's just words on paper
you know words on paper don't mean
anything words don't mean anything it's
just they they they gauge you the way
they gauge each other which is is this
guy going to deliver the kind of
strength that we have to take seriously
and um Trump for whatever whatever
people thought about Trump you know
there were no new Wars uh he was
unpredictable which is an asset you know
in the Middle East and occasionally he
acted with extraordinary determination
and force and it kept at least that part
of the world
uh kept it extremely safe what do you
think Israel could have done differently
I mean so there there's hasn't been an
Israeli or a Jew living in Gaza since
2005 they Egypt also has a border with
that with uh with Gaza obviously and it
was part of Egypt before 1967 I mean
what could they have possibly done every
they said take it we want nothing to do
with this place yeah they and they
really don't want it and they don't want
it back either um but it's sort of like
you know the dog that catches the car I
mean you don't you may not want it but
it wants you you can try to forget Gaza
but gaza's not going to forget you and
um I think there was a lot of Wishful
Thinking look Israel during this period
you know from
2007 when Hamas took over well well
Hamas is is is radicalizing the Gaza
Strip Israel is becoming you know a
first world economy you know their GDP
per capita is is going up to a top 10 in
the world they're they're building
things that nobody ever thought possible
and they don't want to think about you
know the old days you know they want to
get it out of their minds and I think uh
the politicians you know you know
thought that that way as well so every
now and then every 3 four years gasa
would erupt they'd shoot a bunch of
rockets into Israel you know
extraordinarily uh you know uh you know
a war crime of you know undoubtable and
and significant proportions it's funny
you can kind of like brush that away but
no other country on Earth would tolerate
two rockets shot in but but in from that
perspective it's just like ah yeah every
couple so Israel was like how we make
this go away it's not like how do we end
this for the next 20 years how do we
make it go away so they'd shoot back and
there would be some you know back and
forth and then Israel will make an
announcement that you know we have you
know we have caused Hamas to pay a huge
price you know for their their the
malign activities and then cutter would
come in with like a suitcase full of
cash 15 million bucks they'd spread it
by with with Israel's permission spread
it around kind of assuage all the hard
feelings and then Israel will go back
back to creating the most Innovative
technology in the world and becoming the
startup nation and you know you know
what you know what Tel looks like you
know with the most expensive city in the
world to live in and uh and then a few
years later hamasa come back stronger
now they're getting stronger and
stronger and stronger through this
period notwithstanding until we had
October 7th and now you can no longer
ignore it and the only thing Israel
could have done different would have
been to have tried to obliterate Hamas
when it was much weaker than it is today
um the world would have looked at them
like what are you doing like why are you
doing this um in retrospect it would
have been better for everybody including
the Palestinians had Israel gone in uh
10 years ago than now what what does the
end of this thing look
like look I think I think it's a great
question um I I'll tell you what it
doesn't look like because that's you
know there have been all these
suggestions that you know Biden and and
blinkin have said look get rid of Hamas
and then put in the Palestinian
Authority and we'll have a two-state
solution that has zero possibility of
being successful for for two reasons
number one the Palestinian Authority uh
is is is is not that much better than
Hamas they're incredibly corrupt they
pay terrorists to kill Jews they have a
pension system where the more Jews you
kill the higher the pension you get so
they're no good yeah but also the we
don't have that plan here do we we have
a different a different Pension Plan
like totally I hope you don't
I'm I'm going to go out on olym assume
assume you're not have you don't have
that plan it might M our relationship a
little bit for that would be weird that
Cas yeah the other thing is that um the
Palestinians don't want them I mean
oddly enough the Palestinians would
prefer Hamas at this point they have
like a 75% approval rating why because
they committed these atrocities against
you so the one thing that America
refuses to recognize is just how
radicalized the Palestinian people have
become this notion that it's just Hamas
40,000 terrorists and then 2 million
peaceloving people that once Hamas once
the Yoke of Hamas has taken off you have
this great opportunity for peace it's
not true now maybe it'll be true in a
generation or two but the end looks like
um a long period where Israel will be in
control of the Gaza Strip it's going to
retain control of Jude and Samaria
likely with more episodes of violence
there and they're just going to have to
hunker down and and kind of you know uh
try to divide the Palestinians into two
groups and this is what I would do if I
were them this is my vision of the
future you you get a bunch of money from
their friends their new friends in the
gulf and they say guys all you
Palestinians look you want to kill us or
you want to work with us okay let's
forget about all the statecraft for a
minute you want to kill us you want to
work with us you want to kill us we're
going to kill you first okay we're not
going to live with a bunch of guys that
want to kill us you want to work with us
okay we will help build better
infrastructure better better uh better
schools better better hospitals better
roads and try to work with you to get
you to a level where you can start to uh
achieve kind of
comparable quality of life to the
Israeli Arabs who live probably better
than any other Arab people in the entire
Middle East so but but but here are the
choices and make them make the choices
and then act in accordance with those
choices but is the irony though that
that's exactly what they could have had
for the last 17 years right and that
that's sort of the of course of course
what do you do with that
um it's it's the failure of the West see
the West thinks that um that every human
being is the same you know kind of
stripped bare of you know geopolitical
and socioeconomic condition they're all
the same like if you treat them well
every human being will ultimately Veer
towards the good okay it's not the
Middle East I mean there are people look
Osama Bin Laden come came from one of
the wealthiest families in Saudi Arabia
he had a hundred million dollar right
didn't stop them from being radicalized
and being a terrorist it doesn't flow
that just because you're treated nicely
you're going to treat others nicely in
return and that's the Middle East you
got a lot of very very challenging
population centers there surrounding
Israel is the other problem you
mentioned two problems but that there's
another third massive problem which is
that it wouldn't be a two-state solution
it would be a three-state solution and
for some reason nobody talks about that
but the West Bank and Gaza are not
connected and then you have two entities
so it's not a it's not a two-state
solution no nor has ever been now look
there there's there's there's not you
can't create any contiguity between Gaza
and and and the West Bank it's you know
you know you could build a an
underground train if you wanted to but
it it just it would just be silly first
of all you got bigger I mean the
logistics are challenging but the real
problem is who's going to run this you
know there is nobody out there who has
shown any capacity to lead their people
there's no Martin Luther King in the
Palestinian world it is not there's no
one who has that level of inspiration
who wants to live in peace who preaches
peaceful
coexistence it's not part of the culture
you know it's not politically correct to
say these people don't want to live
peacefully but you know for the Israelis
who are living there taking the risk you
know that's the reality you know don't
tell them these are peac loving people
when everything they study and learn and
teach is is designed to just Foster
hatred against the Jewish people is
Israel going to allow the UN and all
these ridiculous Nos and everybody else
back in there to do all of this I mean
they were the ones that were teaching
this stuff and hiding what's going on at
the hospital and everything else um I
don't think so um it it really
highlights the difference between the
administration s me look we we cut off
all funding to the PA we cut off all
funding to unra we said look you want to
teach kids math and science will'll give
you money you know we want we want
everyone to be educated you want to
teach them how to put on a school play
where half the kids dress up as Jews and
half the kids dress up as terrorists and
the and they take the guns and they
shoot the the the Jews and the Jews lie
down and play dead and the parents get
up and applaud we're not giving any
money for that you know and and that's
what a typical you know third grade play
looks like sponsored by the United
Nations in the in Gaza in the Gaza Strip
I want to jump back to the human element
because we could because everyone's
doing the politics everywhere but the
human element you mentioned talking to
your granddaughter as this was happening
um so you're you're a grandfather you
also live in Israel I walked around
Jerusalem with you it was unbelievably
peaceful we had lunch on a beautiful day
and all I kept thinking for those five
days in Jerusalem specifically was how
peaceful it was and I even said to you
as we were walking through the mall
there I said where are all the soldiers
there used to be soldiers everywhere you
said well they they figured out other
ways to do things now that sense when
you're walking around Jerusalem now um
just just gone all together I mean I
guess what I'm asking is what is it like
for a country to now exist in two months
of this how do these people function are
people going to work like what's the
look Jerusalem uh I I I was there two
weeks ago it was wasn't back to normal
because so many people so many fathers
are are off at War you know this is a
reserve Army lots and lots and lots of
guys and and women too are off to the
front so you don't see the the streets
are more quiet but you know there are
people shopping there people walking
around and there I was at the uh I was
at that same Mall walking around it's
just quieter because there aren't that
many people around uh that that will
come back um Jerusalem is um you know
Jerusalem was not bearing the brunt of
this because you know it's interesting
the you Hamas they can't control their
Rockets right so you you shoot an Aaron
rocket towards Tel Aviv if it's long it
hits hia if it's short it hits ashalon
either way you're killing Jews right so
that's all good you shoot a rocket at
the Jerusalem and it goes too far you
could hit the aloa musque right you know
so they don't want to do that well
they'd blame Israel for that they would
blame it but you know there are there
are there is you know there is a way to
prove that so Jerusalem you know was
actually after the first two or three
days the sirens really were were were
not as prevalent but look it's there's a
there's just a a fog that's sitting on
top
of uh of the Jewish people right now
they this is not like anything else um
before not just because um 240 hostages
which is about 238 more than ever before
right so let's put that in perspective
not just
because um The Border was breached at
you know the southern border was
breached which hadn't been breached in
50 years okay but because you saw the
hearts of the Palestinian terrorists and
there weren't any hearts there was like
a piece of coal there I mean the the
violence the the rape the the the
slaughter of children in front of their
parents and parents in front of their
children we looked at that and we
said it doesn't matter what we negotiate
it does matter what we what we what what
the ultimate you know geop geopolitical
you know these people are
barbarians you know you know we used to
say they're animals but they're not
animals because we like animals you know
animals don't don't do this don't hurt
people for pleasure um I think people on
the left you know like like I I I'd
lived this world for 5 years as
Ambassador I spoke to lots and lots of
people and I had spent 30 years you know
negotiating all kinds of things so I I
can size up people pretty quickly I had
sized up a lot of these people you know
early on that you know we're never going
to make a deal with them they're not
worth spending time with I went back and
met with Trump several times in the Oval
Office and gave him my view but there
was always a a movement on the left good
people you know people of good faith
wishful thinking but who said you know
what we can you know if we just kind of
move closer to them they move closer to
us and you know oddly enough most of the
people that were killed in the South
were lefties were lefties these were
people that had dedicated their lives
towards coexisting with the Palestinians
and I think those that survived that's
literally why they were living down
there they wanted to live along the
border and they would you know they'd
meet at the border and they would you
know they they cared so much about
showing that that that they wanted to
coexist and leave live peacefully and
then they wanted to encourage the
Palestinians to improve their lives and
to and to live live better lives and the
the people that survived and saw the
film I think they're I they're the most
in shock because they their their
entire premise about about the
relationship about about living in
Israel their entire premise was you know
proved to be faulty and that's tough you
when when when you're living your life
on a on a 40-year premise and it turns
out to be just completely wrong and
that's that's the toughest part here
because the people that you know and and
that's why that's the other reason why
there'll never be a two-state solution
anymore because it's no longer just
about you know drawing borders and
figuring out you know the details it's
about can we ever again trust these
people to be our neighbors without
protecting ourselves you know um in ways
that they can never do this again so at
the end of the day does this just boil
down to the Jews that that it's just
that these people simply do not want
Jews there no matter what concessions
are made I mean this is what the Israeli
right I mean nany been saying this for a
long time that it doesn't matter what
you give them it doesn't matter what you
offer it doesn't matter what
infrastructure you leave them with or or
whatever else yeah they do not want Jews
there they they simply will never stop
they won't then look they were doing
this in 1929 the big massacre in Hebron
they were doing this long before 1967
when Jordan was in control of the West
Bank I mean this is not about you know
it's it's not about the land it's about
whether or not there can ever be a
Jewish State smack between you know
Lebanon Syria Jordan in Egypt
and you know I mean look look at
Israel's neighbors you know you have a
dictatorship in in uh in Egypt in a
failed economy a dictatorship in Jordan
in a failed economy a a a terrorist
state in Syria with no economy and in a
terrorist state in Lebanon with with no
economy and Israel smack in the middle
now why do they want to inject in the
middle of that another Terror State I
mean the last thing the world needs is
another Terror State smack smack dab in
that in that region and um I I think
Israel is going to hit a point where
they just have to say look you know we
tried we're not going to do it we're
we're willing to live in peace as long
as we have we have to maintain security
control over all of it like like like I
used to always tell my friends who say
you know we want to get out of Gaza I
said again as I said earlier Gaza is not
going to forget you even if you want to
forget Gaza same thing with places like
Janine and rala and the West Bank you
want to get out of there fine it's never
leaving going to leave you alone is
there an irony there that BB didn't want
to leave Gaza in the first place in 2005
so he was right about that but yet this
thing happened under his watch so
there's going to be a a reckoning of
some sort at the end of this well look
um he he he left the government because
he he um was against the Gaza evacuation
he was right there um I think that you
know in the aftermath of that as I said
earlier this idea of plating Hamas just
because you know it's not worth the
distraction on your path to this Eon
economic and technological Juggernaut
you're creating I understand it okay and
and maybe maybe I would have done the
same thing you know in those
circumstances but in hindsight uh Hamas
was allowed to get way too strong given
how how strong their view was to destroy
the state of Israel so as somebody that
now has spent well probably most of your
life but certainly the last couple years
defending Israel on the national stage
explaining the history of the land and
and helping these deals be made and
everything else when you see the
craziness on the Streets of London and
of Paris and in New York City and all of
these places yep and that so many people
are so confused about the reality um
what can be done about this because on a
sheer numbers level uh it's not looking
good in a reality level if we get people
to reality I think it would be just fine
no the numbers are are are terrifying uh
you know you see people yelling from The
River To The Sea palestin only free you
ask them what river and what see they
have no idea yeah they have no idea so
this is just kind of piling on to this
anti-semitic sentiment that has existed
you know across Europe look um the first
thing that look I right now I think the
only country that can really be saved is
America I mean I I just want to save
America you know we're I think we've
lost Europe I I I don't know how to save
it I'm not smart have to figure that out
when I left London just a couple weeks
ago and I D I literally drove by one of
the the rallies and when I was getting
on the plan leaving I thought is this
the last time I'm coming back to this
place that's that's a weird yeah it's
it's it's a shame because London's a
great City and Paris is a great City but
not anymore not anymore so we got to
save America I mean that's that's really
I think and that's really important to
Israel also at the end of the day Israel
you know if Israel only has an alliance
with America and no one else Israel
would be fine Israel without America
scares me that that that really scares
me now it's all about it's it's all
about some basic things and I I don't
want to make this political but shut the
freaking border you know get rid of the
people who don't deserve to be here you
know I mean it's we
have that that's what happened to London
and in Paris right they let everybody in
and they're they're paying the price we
can't replicate you know London and
Paris and um so that's that's the first
thing I think if we do that now as far
as you know University is concerned look
my alma moer that I'm totally uh
offended by it Point Columbia University
uh I started you know kind of talking to
people there what they tell me is that
there are more Palestinian teaching
assistants at Columbia University than
any other nationality and these are the
ones that are teaching the kids I mean
they're they're teaching all Bas just by
numbers that makes absolutely no sense
it makes no sense I mean certainly
they're not that large a population they
have a lot of support within the Middle
East studies Department you know they
Columbia began with this fellow Edward S
who kind of was the intellectual founder
of the Palestinian Liberation movement
and he's got all his people in there and
um you know I would bet that you know
they all got student visas uh and and
lied on on the question whether they
support a terrorist organization so if
if they've lied on their visa
application send them home I mean we
have to get really tough on who's in our
country we have I I I I think there were
a lot of dumb kids at College I mean but
there have always been dumb kids at
College I mean you know that's what
college is known for um the the energy
behind that that those those dumb kids
ripping down posters of kidnapped
children is coming from The Faculty of
these universities and you know look one
thing that you know people don't realize
this you know but you know you know
people call Donald Trump you know all
the time anti-semitic I have no idea why
okay certainly anything that they've
attributed to him they've misquoted I
don't think his grandchildren know why
either I don't think his grandchildren
know why I mean and I know you know
personally know that he's not but you
know in December of 2019 he signed an
executive order that extended the reach
of title 6 to uh to religious groups the
title six says you can't have any
federal funding to an institution and a
university that discriminates based upon
race or gender didn't say religion okay
because after the uh Pittsburgh shooting
he signs an executive order that says I
want to combat anti-Semitism I want to
extend this to anti-semitic acts as well
anybody discriminates against Jews no
more Federal funding okay we got to
enforce that I think aggressively and if
we do that because again what what you
know there there's some really good
organizations right now that are
fighting anti-Semitism you know how they
go and they photograph every single
every single idiot on a college campus
saying something really stupid and then
they figure out how to work the Google
algorithm so that when you Google their
name it's the first thing you see yeah
okay that will quickly I think end you
know the the uprisings from from the
idiots not from the ideological
motivated people but the idiots they say
we can't get we can't we can't get jobs
if we keep doing this so they'll stop
doing it you know you know and I think
that's a step in the right direction but
we got to be tough on our on our borders
tough on our illegal immigrants tough on
the those that support Hamas and tough
on the faculty at these universities and
I think if we do all those things um we
we'll be moving in the right direction
and I don't think the Democrats will do
that I think I think we have a
republican Administration will will do
that what has happened to the
Democrats well there they they're
they're they're they're falling apart
right now because you know the the the
the Democrats that my parents used to
support you know you know I I call him
sort of like the the stenny Hoyer
Democrats right you know guy you know
Centrist you know pro-israel been around
for 40 50 years you know goes to every
APAC you know
meeting that that's not where the energy
is in the party anymore and um I think a
lot of Jewish people who traditionally
voted Democrat a lot of a lot of people
kind of are Center or Center left who
supported the Democratic party um Jewish
a lot of Jews I think they're looking at
what's happening now and saying you know
what happened to our party it's not it's
never been my party but it's I think the
um I think the Democrats are going you
know and you know you know where you saw
it first you remember um I think it was
two Democratic conventions ago right
where oh when they wanted to take God
out of is that no when they wanted to
when they wanted to make part of the
platform that Jerusalem was the capital
of Israel and oh right and they got
shattered out and then this guy says
look you know I'm just going to take it
to a Voice vote you know let's just B
our platform to include that Jerusalem
is the capital of Israel The Voice vote
was negative you could hear in the crowd
they were saying no and he said okay the
eyes have it he he put it in right but
right there I could tell you know you
could tell that the party is no longer
with Israel yeah so have you got any uh
apologies from the Lefty Jews that might
have been annoyed with you for working
with Donald Trump who suddenly are like
all right all right wasn't so bad I I
some I do sense some Lefty Jews are
waking up right now there there are a
certain set of lefties in general but
obviously with Jews it's a little more
specific maybe yeah I think look I think
no no no one's no one's come to me and
and apologized but I do think that they
are in pain right now they're they're
looking at you know all look a lot of
these Lefty Jews went to the colombias
and the Harvard and the Princeton and
the mits and they're seeing what's
happening on campus and they're seeing
that the left is becoming decidedly not
just anti-israel but
anti-semitic and I think they're I think
it's I I can only imagine how they feel
they feel betrayed they feel like you
know again when you when you believe in
something your whole life and it turns
out to be false it's probably not a
pleasant not AA pleasant experience you
know and I think that's where they are
right now is there anything else Israel
can do on the messaging side you know
because obviously the lies travel fast
they are Amplified by algorithms now
they're Amplified by the BBC and this
CBC and virtually everywhere and then
Israel sends out people to correct the
lies but it's it's a hell of a lot of
work look I think where and also some
people just simply don't care it's just
Jews are the oppressor or that's it look
I think that um uh and I'm sure lots of
people won't agree with this but I think
that what Israel has failed to really um
um communicate is the message that
they're not just um you know a state
surrounded by hostile Arabs that they're
not just a democratic state that they're
not just a place where you know people
can live who are who are gay or trans or
or you know Arab or Christian that you
know that they were an inclus I mean
that's that's all true and it is unique
about a state in the Middle East but
they've lost I think they buried the
lead right and and again the lead may
not appeal to everybody but the lead is
that it's also the land of the Bible you
know and and the Bible still sells more
books than you know I last time I
checked it sells like 2400 books an hour
okay the Bible matters I mean you know
the values that we hold dear in America
came from the Bible I mean you know the
Declaration of Independence says that
you know human rights were endowed by
our creator right that was Earth shaking
because it meant that they're not
negotiable they're not they're immutable
right they come from God if they come
from God you can't you can't change them
The Sovereign can't change them and um
in all those rights you know uh you know
life liberty The Pursuit of
Happiness they're sourced right in the
Bible I mean you know you can look in
the Bible and see exactly where our
Founders got those rights versus any
other you know human rights and um if we
want to preserve ve our our Biblical
Heritage or at least the biblical values
whether we're observant or not it's not
about being religious or not but about
observing you know these these these
ancient but still relevant
judeo-christian values if we want to
preserve them okay you got to get there
every now and then you got to get there
and you got to recharge your batteries
and you got to see where the covenants
were given to Abraham Isaac and Jacob
you got to see the path where Jesus
walked you got to see where the messages
were delivered it really is um you know
a life-altering experience for people to
do it at least once and you can only do
it if the Jewish people retain control
of the Jewish State okay otherwise it
will go the way of all the other
judeo-christian monuments that have been
destroyed you know by ISIS and others so
um that doesn't come across because you
know I'm not
sure I'm not sure how many um how much
of the Israeli population really wants
to emphasize that point I mean Israel is
you know we're all Jews but it's it's
it's largely a secular society but we
can't lose sight of that I'm telling you
it it really is important it resonates
deeply within America you know and um
and I and again you could think the
Bible comes from God you could think it
was just written by some really really
smart guy you know 3,000 years ago you
know who who just had some really great
ideas and but but the book's the book
you know and we're the people of the
book and that book is the reason why the
Jewish people are still around today
3,500 years later when every other
ancient civilization is gone it's the
book it's the book that kep kept us
together again what you believe in God
or not the book kept us together we
should be focusing more on the book I
don't think there's a better way to end
this than saying next year in Jerusalem
next year in Jerusalem this no this year
in Jerusalem this year in Jer well
you'll be there in a couple weeks but
I'll make it for 24 how about that
looking forward Dave all right pleasure
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell